bienvenue dans ce journal c'est donc une
vaste chasse à l'homme qui est engagée
depuis la mi journée dans la banlieue de
paris et qui est toujours en cours ce
soir un groupe de cinq malfaiteurs est
recherché ils n'ont pas hésité à tirer à
l'armé automatique en pleine rue faisant
un lourd bilan
les policiers très choquée pensent avoir
affaire à des hommes prêts à tout et
particulièrement violent loïc de la
mornais marie cros l'hélicoptère du samu
vient d'emmener la policière dans un
état désespéré
cette jeune femme qui quelques minutes
plus tôt a juste voulu porter secours
aux occupants de ce fourgon accidenté
mais de cette carcasse sortent plusieurs
hommes cagoulés qui ouvre le feu au
fusil mitrailleur
le véhicule de police municipale est
perforé de part en part
l'équipée sauvage a débuté plutôt aux
environs de créteil
des policiers sont intrigués par un
véhicule suspect ils appellent des
renforts arrivés sur l'a4 au pont de
nogent celle escalade
il ya une première fusillade qui
éclatent les malfrats épaules des fusils
d'assaut pistolet mitrailleur et tire
tous azimuts en direction des collègues
et en direction bien entendu des
multiples conducteurs qui sont présents
à 9h45 du matin plusieurs automobilistes
sont blessées dont une femme touchée par
balles au poumon
puis les malfaiteurs sortent à
villiers-sur-marne cause un accident
c'est là que le drame se joue l'autre
policier municipal aurait réussi à
riposter petter était là pour les tuer
comme des chiens et heureusement pu
répliquer
et ont touché 1 les malfaiteurs braquent
ensuite un autre véhicule et réussissent
à prendre la fuite
les responsables seront inéluctablement
tôt ou tard identifiés interpellés et
déférés et sanctions et ils paieront
pour leurs actes effondré les policiers
municipaux apprennent à cet instant que
leurs jeunes collègues de 27 ans est en
état de mort cérébrale recentrer sur
l'émotion ressentie sur la disparition
d'une jeune collègue jeune maman qui
laisse un bébé de 14 mois derrière elle
c'est aujourd'hui la plus forcément
d'honneur il ya plus forcément de bons
tirs
il faut coûte que coûte qu on réchappe
et qu'on échappe à une interpellation
le bilan final est lourd en plus de la
jeune policière deux autres policiers et
cinq automobilistes ont été blessés
[Musique]